We are taking your calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50.
Let's go to our caller from the 5 7 1 area
code who's calling today from 5 7 1.
Sadhus Rodriguez.
Hey, Rodrigo, it's up.
And now I just want to ask you.
Oh, we all like seeing the news and everything
and how like Fox and like.
Slowly and then how they interpret things
versus how CNN approach interpret things,
those asked like.
How do you think future generations are going
to look at this, because there's obviously
like the worst president maybe any country
has ever had.
Yeah, handling.
This, Slaten, you get what I mean?
I mean, sort of an out and out totalitarian
murderer.
We've got a pretty bad president right now.
Yeah.
So my question really is like, how do you
think this is going to play for future generations?
Look at this and this pandemic.
It can be like, how are they going to view
this president and your opinion?
You know, the pandemic is harder to say.
But as far as you know, the retrospective
on how Trump will be viewed in the future.
My fear is and this is ultimately going to
come down to historians to deal with.
My fear is that because for everything Trump
has ever done, there's always been a propaganda
counter-narrative.
Right.
So like if 20 years from now you want to look
back and say what was being said about Trump's
handling of the virus at the time, what was
being said about Trump's Ukraine, you know,
corruption at the time, what you can find
people who defend Trump no matter what he
does.
So I worry that the widespread availability
of this it this disinformation on the Internet
is going to prevent future generations from
accurately understanding the horrors of what
we are seeing right now.
I think that that's a very serious concern.
It might as well, David, France will talk
to you about this.
I have no idea what's really going on because
nobody watches Fox News.
And so give me an example like this.
Is that as far as the virus?
What are some of the things your friends are
still saying?
Not set like the virus, others are being taken
seriously, do understand how much Trump screwed
up like we could have Salt Lake because they
know how South Korea already has it under
control so much.
And we had the same like we started the same
day with the virus.
Right.
And they don't understand, like the degree
that Trump actually screwed it up.
And like, he just talks like everything's
under control and a reports lies about how
serious it is.
And I'm just afraid that they're not going
to realize how much this person actually screwed
the country over.
It's likely that they won't.
Now, let me ask you this.
Are your friends who think Trump did a good
job?
Are they also not really worrying about the
virus and just going out and acting like they
shouldn't be staying home?
Stumblebum.
Yeah, I'm a pretty young guy, so like in other
20, they're not really concerned about it.
Yeah.
Some of them just the lack of information.
I guess some people are just I guess nowadays
just don't watch news, but they do watch state.
Sometimes you get the wrong information.
That's all they believe.
Yeah.
No, I believe this is a major concern.
It's good that you're thinking about it because
when the history books are written about this
era, we want them written accurately.
And of course, different people have a different
view as to what that means.
But the amount of disinformation propaganda
could keep completely alternative narratives
about the Trump administration going for decades,
hundreds of years.
Is it possible and that's a scary thing because
we've got to learn from our mistakes.
Very much as I will, David Gratings now this
group.
Rodrigo, thank you so much.
Very appreciate very much.
Appreciate the phone call.